[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous durant
cette demi-heure et lui de la
Haute-Marne donc du groupe les
républicains rapporteur du budget des
collectivités territoriales dont on va
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord un mot sur celle qui est
désormais l'ancienne ministre des
collectivités territoriales Caroline
cailleux qui a du démissionner du
gouvernement suspecté par la Haute
Autorité des finances publiques de
fraude fiscal elle conteste le montant
de la sous-estimation de ses biens
puisque la Haute Autorité lui reproche
d'avoir sous-estime et c'est bien
immobilier est-ce qu'elle était une
bonne ministre des collectivités
territoriales
pourquoi c'est non c'est une amie en
plus je la connais depuis longue date
c'était une collègue au Sénat bon elle a
elle a débuté je veux dire son son
métier si j'ose dire il y a quelques
quelques mois puisque avant elle était à
la NCT où elle a dû mettre en place
disons une une un nouveau dispos et là
elle prenait ses marques bon je veux
dire comme tout
on regrette toujours le départ d'un
collègue mais bon
d'un ancien collègue qui était devenu
ministre même s'il était pas
totalement dans nos rangs puisque comme
vous le savez elle avait changé mais bon
voilà c'est une ça la regarde maintenant
c'est quand même Paris
la justice tranchera elle regardera si
c'est simplement une sous-évaluation ou
une suspicion de fraude fiscale il y a
quand même une grande différence entre
les deux termes et je crois que c'est là
que se situe la difficulté alors du coup
c'est Dominique Faure qui récupère son
portefeuille elle était jusque là
chargée de la ruralité qui était un
ministère à part j'ai envie de vous dire
est-ce que là vous regrettez justement
que c'est qu'il n'y ait plus de
ministère dédié un pour les relations
avec les collectivités et un spécifique
à la réalité
pour l'instant je veux dire on ne sait
pas d'ailleurs si ça va demeurer comme
ça on a fait la connaissance
plus
de Dominique Faure hier soir elle-même
nous a dit écoutez sur certaines
questions écoutez je suis avant arrivé
avant-hier j'ai eu le temps de prendre
le dossier mais quand même bon donc
c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez difficile pour
elle bon c'est vrai
de ministère spécifique c'est vrai qu'on
préférait avoir deux interlocuteurs ça
ça permettait je veux dire de mieux
embrasser un petit peu les questions
mais bon voilà on va dire on va pas on
fera avec
et on va continuer à parler des
collectivités puisque le Sénat poursuit
l'examen du budget hier les sénateurs
se sont penchés pardon justement sur ce
budget des collectivités territoriales
vous en êtes le rapporteur on va voir
les temps forts de la séance avec Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
avec les collectivités territoriales oui
avec une partie très technique mais
quelques points importants que je vais
rappeler hier les sénateurs ont votés
pour qu'il n'y ait plus de critères de
superficie quand il s'agit d'octroyer
les dotations de solidarité en cas de
catastrophe naturelle pour une meilleure
prise en compte aussi de l'avis des
collectivités quand il s'agit de
discuter avec les préfets et pour un
élargissement des aides en faveur de la
biodiversité mais hier vous en avez
surtout profité pour faire passer
quelques messages à la ministre la toute
nouvelle ministre Dominique Faure
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales après vous
l'avez rappelé le départ de Caroline
cailleux et c'était un peu son baptême
du feu hier à la ministre face à des
sénateurs bien décidés à monter au
créneau pour les collectivités il faut
dire que c'est même collectivités font
face à de très nombreux défis
augmentation du prix des énergies
inflation les sénateurs s'en sont faits
le relais écouter
les maires que nous côtoyons sont
inquiets beaucoup voient leur budget
déséquilibré difficile à boucler avec
l'explosion des dépenses d'énergie le
renchérissement des produits
alimentaires celui des marchés de
travaux nos collectivités sont au cœur
de l'investissement public et sont en
première ligne pour aider nos
concitoyens leurs services publics
doivent être préservés à fortiorer dans
un contexte économique difficile il nous
reviennent nous assurer qu'elles seront
soutenues dans cette période et ce
soutien peut et doit prendre plusieurs
formes les aides exceptionnelles certes
mais pas au détriment des tentations
budgétaires annuels et des concours
financiers classiques en fait ce que le
sénateur rénal pointe du doigt c'est que
même si les budgets restent stables dans
un contexte d'inflation il y a forcément
moins d'argent pour les collectivités et
ça peut mener à une baisse des
investissements ça a donné lieu aussi à
des propos un peu contradictoires entre
les sénateurs d'un côté et la ministre
notamment Loïc Hervé et puis la ministre
on va les écouter et on en reparle tout
de suite après
les crédits à l'échelle de la mission
enregistre une baisse particulièrement
regrettable de 12,84% en autorisation
d'engagement un périmètre constant les
concours financiers de l'État aux
collectivité sont en hausse de 1,4
milliards d'euros par rapport à 2022
sans compter les amendements qui seront
adoptés sur la mission notamment le
complément de la compensation CVAE qui
abordera le fond vert alors je n'ai
choisi que de très petits extrêmes et
c'est un peu l'impression qu'il ressorti
hier monsieur le sénateur on avait
l'impression que vous me parliez pas de
la même chose avec la ministre vous avez
souligné une baisse pour les
collectivités elle avait l'air de dire
que tout était stable que qu'elle
investissait pour les collectivités
finalement vous parlez pas de la même
chose
si mais quelque part vous savez nous ne
défendons pas toujours le même aspect
des choses je crois que le gouvernement
beaucoup des élus auraient souhaité une
augmentation de la DGF quelque chose de
de très de très net etc et le c'est la
dotation globale de fonctionnement c'est
la principale dotation pour les
collectivités
obsolète et il n'est pas utile d'indexer
un outil obsolète il vaut mieux soit le
changer
soit consacrer l'augmentation des
crédits à une une attribution aux
collectivités qui s'effectue d'une
manière plus juste c'est quelque part
peut-être le choix qu'a fait le
gouvernement mais il le fait d'une
manière insidieusement il se débrouille
pour retrouver des marches de manœuvre
qui lui qui lui sont propres puisque
effectivement il a mis une partie sur la
DSR etc mais il en profite aussi pour
mettre sur le fond vert etc comme de
nouveau crédit mais qui en fait
correspondent à une indexation en fait à
cette inflation en réalité et tout
compte fait au final ce que veulent dire
mes collègues c'est que le compte n'est
pas tout à fait même si facialement ça
paraît très très large comme attribution
mais juste sur le on va parler après du
fond vert et de la question de l'énergie
mais de l'écologie pardon mais justement
sur la question de l'énergie est-ce que
il faut des aides supplémentaires pour
les collectivités face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie ou est-ce que ce qu'il
y a dans le budget est suffisant
disons que nos militons pour que les
aides soient à la hauteur du défi et
alors qu'il est il est évident qu'il est
très difficile de savoir quel sera le
montant d'aide nécessaire pour
équilibrer à la fois cette hausse des
indices et cette hausse de l'énergie et
tout le travail que des sénateurs ont
essayé de faire c'est de peaufiner et de
parfaire ce dernier fil vous savez qu'il
y a un triple dispositif dans lequel on
va pas camper d'ailleurs voilà et si
vous voulez quand il y a un fille qui
dit filet cherche à faire en sorte que
les mailles du filet ne soit pas trop
large et finalement qu'il n'y ait pas de
trou dans la raquette comme on dit et
c'est ce que nous avons essayé de faire
et nous espérons que notre travail sera
repris une fine et la semaine prochaine
il y a une proposition de là des
communistes qui sera examinée pour
étendre à toutes les collectivités les
tarifs réglementés de l'énergie vous la
voterez
on examinera exactement son contenu mais
ne disons que nos
directions convergent quelque part on
est tous sur la focaliser sur les mêmes
directions pour essayer de faire en
sorte que les communes arrivent à s'en
sortir sans trop de dégâts
faudrait les sénateurs ont du mal à
digérer les contrats de Cahors le retour
au contrat de l'or que vous l'imposer le
gouvernement oui même si la ministre est
finalement revenu dessus la semaine
dernière à l'occasion de l'AMF elle a
dit qu'il n'y aurait pas c'est ces
fameux compte enfin ce qui rappelle les
contrats de Cahors et bien hier c'était
quand même au cœur de beaucoup de
discussions pour vous faire un petit
rappel le gouvernement voulait l'imposer
par 49-3 à l'Assemblée nationale cette
encadrement des dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités donc je
l'ai dit ça n'a pas du tout été accepté
c'était une sorte de ligne rouge le
gouvernement donc a fait machine arrière
mais hier on en parlait beaucoup et
pourtant ce n'était pas au cœur des
discussions écoutez
en dépit des efforts réalisés par les
aigus locaux pour tenter de contenir les
dépenses et boucler leur budget en cette
période de crise l'exécutif sera adressé
un coup extrêmement brutal en
réintégrant par la voix du 49-3 les
contrats de Cahors le message du
gouvernement est clair qu'importe les
associations des locaux la vie du Sénat
ou le vote négatif de la majorité des
députés il imposera sa trajectoire de
rigueur budgétaire ou collectivités et
le mécanisme punitif aveugle qui
l'accompagne le sénateur loïcardv a même
parlé d'un climat de défiance est-ce
qu'il y a un climat de défiance entre
les élus et le gouvernement je crois que
au Sénat nous avons essayé de défendre
trois axes on parlera sans doute des
autres mais il n'y en a un qui est qui
est vraiment une ligne rouge vous l'avez
dit c'est la libre administration des
collectivités elles n'ont déjà plus
pratiquement d'autonomie fiscale ou très
peu et donc il y a cette libre
administration et ces fameux des contrat
de cas hors ou de aujourd'hui ce qu'on
aurait souhaité le gouvernement aurait
souhaité des contrats de confiance ne
sont pas acceptables par les études et
je crois que
nous obtiendrons gain de cause je veux
pas dire que nous l'avons obtenu parce
que mais je crois que le Sénat s'est
fait entendre et que le gouvernement a
compris que ça ne passerait pas
des maires de France
continuent de loi de décentralisation
vous y croyez dans ce second quinquennat
écoutez quand on est élu il faut quand
même croire en certaines choses et
il faudrait sans doute alors une
nouvelle grande loi je crois que
personne enfin je dirais tout le monde
en a marre des grandes lois mais il faut
se dire que tout le monde veut plus de
décentralisation on est d'accord et
cette décentralisation aussi sans parler
du volet financier ça n'a pas beaucoup
de sens et le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
la question financière et fiscale a
tellement évolué dans ces dernières
années c'est à dire que
les collectivités n'ont plus l'autonomie
qu'elles avaient auparavant on leur
distribue des impôts nationaux et il
faut bien savoir c'est c'est d'État qui
maîtrisent absolument tout et à partir
de ce moment-là si vous décentralisez il
faut que les ressources avec et il faut
donc qu'il y ait une nouvelle
gouvernance qui soit mise en place et de
nouveaux moyens attribués pour que cette
décentralisation effective et vous
sentez le gouvernement prêt Emmanuel
Macron prêt je pense pas que ce soit sa
préoccupation actuelle et donc je pense
que il a peut-être du souci à se faire
de la part des collectivités parce que
je veux dire c'est la seule voie qui
leur reste ouverte pour leur libre
administration et je pense que elles
vont monter au créneau à chaque fois et
bon les collectivités qui Emmanuel
Macron
plutôt de ce côté-là qui qui a besoin de
calme et de paisibilité de ce côté-là
vous avez acté un élargissement des
aides en faveur de la biodiversité
Emmanuel Macron veut inclure les maires
dans la transition écologique est-ce
qu'il en fait assez est-ce qu'il y a
assez de moyens à donner à ses mères
vous savez la
le texte sur la biodiversité que nous
avons regardé hier soir n'est qu'un
un petit un petit aspect de la
biodiversité puisqu'il s'adresse en fait
au territoire Natura 2000 au parc
nationaux et au parc régionaux et le
c'est certes déjà un budget intéressant
en particulier des terrains pour des
territoires comme comme le mien mais je
veux dire la biodiversité et la
transition énergétique est un problème
beaucoup plus vaste qui va demander une
beaucoup plus grande réflexion à la fois
au Parlement aux élus et au gouvernement
parce que nous en sommes qu'au
balbutiements et ça n'est pas le fond
vert même si etc qui va suffire dans ce
domaine c'est une véritable révolution
mais justement sur ce fond vert est-ce
que vous y voyez clair sur acquis les
destiné comment il sera attribué quel
sera le montant des aides parce que là
on a une grosse enveloppe mais dans le
détail vous savez d'abord l'enveloppe
n'est pas assez grosse que ça à
l'échelon des investissements des
collectivités mais on voit mais on voit
parfaitement que euh les lignes ne sont
pas encore définies et finalement le
gouvernement est pour l'instant c'est
justement ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
il y aura une une annexation des
dotations etc tandis que là le
gouvernement se sert de cela pour faire
un peu du One Shot si j'emploie un
mauvais terme mais je veux dire c'est on
met l'argent une fois cette année et en
fait l'année suivante on pourra faire ce
qu'on veut ça n'est pas quelque chose de
définitif et je pense que la transition
énergétique
exigera de la constance dans l'effort
sur un temps d'un beaucoup plus long
merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure oui on
va parler des festivals en 2024 si vous
avez prévu d'y aller ça risque d'être
compliqué mais oui on verra pourquoi
quel tisane on verra ça dans une
demi-heure allez on va aller voir
l'actualité du côté de votre département
vachement retrouvez Céline Clément
bonjour journaliste à la rédaction de la
haute du Journal de la Haute-Marne
quotidien bonjour Céline merci d'être
avec nous la ministre de la transition
énergétique Agnès ruincher est en visite
à Bure sur le site du projet de centre
d'enfouissement des déchets radioactifs
oui et le président de la ministre
président d'aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
le comité de de haut niveau c'est une
réunion importante à la fois pour bien
sûr l'État mais aussi les collectivités
locales dans une interview quel
effectivement qu'elle accorde à GHM
quotidien paru ce jour
agnès panier rue nacher par le d'un
projet qui doit être gagnant gagnant
alors gagnant pour la nation bien sûr
mais aussi gagnant pour les territoires
donc aujourd'hui à Bure et à chaudron il
va être question décompensation
financière
attendue et espérée par les territoires
dont la Haute-Marne
quel serait ce pour vous monsieur le
sénateur une fiscalité juste pour la
Haute-Marne et pour la Meuse
bonjour Céline
une fiscalité juste ça peut délicat
parce que on part sur des conventions
anciennes vous savez avec ce département
voisin il y avait du 60-40 etc bon
et puis vous savez que les installations
ne sont pas forcément partagées de
manière rigoureuse alors bon je pense
que la fiscalité
juste c'est déjà au regard du National
il faut qu'on ait une fiscalité
exceptionnelle
et d'ailleurs jusqu'à présent l'état
l'avait compris puisque vous savez qu'on
avait des dotations qui étaient
substantielle pour ce territoire qui
avait accepté comme on le dit souvent
une mission on était un peu terre de
mission on n'était pas légion à vouloir
accepter
disons cette cette aventure de Cigéo et
donc il faut que on puisse
tirer quelque part les avantages de des
efforts que nous avons fait et ensuite
il y a le partage entre les deux
département vous savez on prend 60 40 ou
un 55 ans je pense que
tout le monde sera satisfait l'essentiel
c'est que aujourd'hui
la Haute-Marne ainsi que la Meuse
perçoivent globalement 30 millions
d'euros par an
dans le domaine de justement pour
accompagner le développement de ce
projet est-ce que selon vous l'État doit
aller au-delà c'est ce qui semble être
attendu en tout cas par par les
collectivités
ça paraît je veux dire cette somme on
parle aujourd'hui de d'une certaine
inflation etc je vois pas pourquoi les
les élus aux marnais verraient cette
somme baissée surtout qu'auparavant il
n'y avait pas d'activité majeures sur le
site et que c'est probablement
maintenant qui qu'il peut y avoir des
des surcoûts et des nécessités
d'investissement plus larges comme on le
sait et je pense que pour y faire face
si nous avons
une somme supérieure ça ne peut être que
légitime je pense qu'il faut l'espérer
c'est du moins le rôle de tout élu qui
fait son travail quoi
Céline sujet d'inquiétude dans des élus
locaux c'est la question de la zéro
artificialisation nette des sols
oui alors sur le sujet si j'ai bien
suivi la première ministre à lâché un
petit peu de l'Est la semaine dernière
en clôture du du Congrès des Maires
alors ma question est simple en fait
est-ce que vous savez ce que vous est-ce
que vous en savez un peu plus sur
les éventuels aménagements des décrets
voir la réécriture de certains décrets
par rapport à par rapport à ce
dispositif est-ce que vous connaissez un
petit peu plus finement ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à lâcher sur ce
dispositif qui est source d'inquiétude
bien sûr pour les territoires ruraux on
en sait un peu plus mais peut-être
faut-il expliquer brièvement si vous
voulez le principe est que chaque
territoire va devoir avoir une sorte de
quota pour
l'expansion qu'il qu'il doit qu'il
pourrait faire que ce soit en terme
économique ou en termes d'habitation
c'est à dire il ne pourra pas gagner sur
les terres agricoles etc et donc toute
la question est de savoir quelle est la
référence qu'on prend et alors le
problème c'est que a priori est pris ce
qu'on a fait auparavant et donc quelque
part ce sont les plus vertueux qui sont
pénalisés puisque si vous en avez moins
fait vous ne pourrez pas en faire plus
et se pose également la question des
grands projets de type nationaux etc
comment on les compte sur les
territoires parce que lorsque vous avez
un projet par exemple comme bure qui va
vous prendre un développement de surface
assez importante vous ne pourrez plus
rien faire ailleurs sur le territoire
concerné et particulièrement le
département donc jusqu'à l'État semble
l'avoir compris et devrait soustraire
une grande partie où la plupart de des
grands projets nationaux et c'est là que
doit être écrit un décret et où voter
des des lois qui qui sont nécessaires
lors de la clôture du Congrès des mains
est-ce qu'il y a un risque de clivage
entre urbain et ruraux de fracture
déjà le
l'esprit lui-même
déjà et source de clivage parce que
c'est forcément le territoires
urbains qui qui se sont développés lors
de ces dernières années de manière
exponentielle ce qui veut dire que pour
les ruraux c'est a priori un jeu perdant
perdant et donc il faut quand même
regarder parce que la plupart des des
mères qui se respectent ont envie de
développer leur territoire alors
effectivement on nous dit vous avez des
dents creuses à l'intérieur de vos
villages vous voudriez les faire sauf
que dans des territoires comme les
nôtres ça coûte quelquefois deux ou
trois fois plus cher quand ça n'est pas
5 de réhabiliter des
des espaces abandonnés
ça pourrait être imaginé ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'il faudrait aller à du
n'importe quoi parce que on connaît
aussi nos territoires et on a vu des
expansions qui quelquefois des naturels
aussi les paysages gagnaient un peu trop
sur des espaces agricoles donc il
faudrait arriver à trouver une sorte de
régime spécial pour des territoires
comme léonautes de ruralité ou hyper
ruralité c'est le rôle probablement des
parlementaires merci Céline Clément
merci beaucoup avec nous bonne idée
en garde la une énergie comment faire
des économies c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous un mot sur la de politique sur la
course à la présidence des républicains
puisque le vote c'est à partir de samedi
soir jusqu'à dimanche soir est-ce que
vous redoutez que cette course à la
présidence et des conséquences sur le
groupe ici au Sénat Bruno Retailleau est
l'un des candidats le président du
groupe effectivement dans toute élection
il peut y avoir un risque mais je pense
que le Sénat est bien campé sur sur son
grand basse comme on le dit souvent et
je pense qu'il devrait être traversé
cette épreuve quelle que soit l'issue
sans trop de difficultés même si l'une
des issues feraient craindre que ce soit
plus compliqué
bien je sais pas encore vous savez sans
doute que le Sénat plus largement fait
l'option Bruno Retailleau ça surprend
pas trop dans notre groupe parce que il
semblait moins clivant
au plan national que notre ami erikioti
donc il y a une hypothèse qui serait
peut-être plus grande mais
je ne le crois pas merci Charles Gonnet
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on va parler sport en
débriefera le match des Bleus avec deux
sénateurs fans de foot David et Soline
et Stéphane piennois et puis on parlera
également des Jeux olympiques mais
d'abord on va accueillir notre invité
politique c'est Sébastien Chenu qui nous
rejoint